goats in a bad way i'll give you the
first pick because i'm in a somewhat
good mood okay great i'm glad you're
well i'll go with aaron rodgers then yep
i'm gonna i mean it's my guy we know it
yes i love him but damn it's ten nothing
we need you to take care of the freaking
football okay aaron rodgers and he did
not unlike him yes we know but that was
a big turnover and a big moment against
a team that was better than them and
they needed him to play
a
somewhat perfect aaron rodgers type of
football game there and that certainly
gave the bucks a breath of fresh air got
them off the schnide a little bit and
got them going and then of course there
was another turnover after that but that
was not a good rogers performance i
think those two interceptions flustered
him and did affect him in the rest of
the game let alone the pass rush and
that talented defense with the
buccaneers
that's why i gave you the first pick
thank you you'd pick him you have you
have really cooled in your i just keep
it real i just keep it on the other hand
i've remained consistent in my
assessment of kirk cousins who will be
my first pick
first pick first pass right out of the
gate reception a three interception day
and
look
he made it worse after the game by
saying if i keep throwing interceptions
i won't be playing kirk look at the
depth chart your backup is sean mannion
yes you will still be playing you have
to throw a lot of interceptions to get
benched for sean freaking mannion all
due respect to sean mannion but i think
it's probably too late for that but it's
it's just not working it's not working
this year whatever the reasoning whether
you got guys who think they're on
scholarship whether kirk was just never
very good you know he he he's he like i
said yesterday he's just good enough to
be bad he's just good enough to be to be
in a high profile spot where he can't
get it done he's been competent enough
throughout his career to earn the
opportunity to be a
a mid-level and at times not good enough
starting quarterback that's where he is
and he's gotten paid a crapload of money
to do it he's won show's over doesn't
matter what he does from this point
forward with all the money he's made but
uh i and the vikings uh are stuck for
two more years after this one unless
they work out some sort of financial
magic with his contract yeah i listen i
i get it and it's not a good day by kirk
cousins yes i don't care how what he is
you can't start the game off making
those type of mistakes and putting them
you know in such a tough spot like that
a reeling football team and like you
heard me say yesterday again i don't
think they do him a whole lot of justice
by the way they formulated that scheme
and offense around him too
but either way we make that type of
money and those dumb mistakes you get on
the goat draft
right and here's the other thing too
yeah somebody in that organization had
to be the ones to say don't let what
happened in seattle linger tom brady's
not going to let it linger the great
quarterbacks are not going to let it
linger and turn it in as you said into
two losses so part of that's on him too
yeah i get that that is it's part of a
quarterback to be able to turn the
narrative around and change the the mojo
of the football team um
well
you've got a quarterback that threw an
interception on their first pass i'll
see that quarterback and raise it with
another quarterback who threw an
interception on their first pass baker
mayfield i mean come on
the cleveland freaking browns the
biggest game you guys have had in
forever like oh are they for real we're
all tuned in
and when he threw that interception we
went uh
i think they're not for real like this
is gonna be trouble it just you knew
right then you were going uh oh here we
go
and yes to kind of start the game off
that way
to put your team down you know right off
the bat like that uh that's that's
brutal that way that really is now
they're down ten nothing and of course
the interception he throws later in the
second quarter is almost as egregiously
as bad in fact you text me yesterday i
think when you were watching it like
what the hell was he doing on the second
interception i don't know and that's
where baker mayfield he's got talent we
know that but man
inaccurate and they have to manage them
to a degree right now and that's where
it's a little scary
something about baker mayfield when when
everything's going well it's fine when
it's not going well he just doesn't even
look like a quarterback like there's
something about his pads or something
about his blackjack if there's something
about his build there's something about
the way he moves where he just doesn't
look like he should be playing
quarterback and it's
in on the days when it's not working on
the days when it's working it's not
noticeable on the days when it's not
working it's like
are we sure that this is the guy is it
is this him did you send the right guy
off the sideline because he just doesn't
look like a quarterback and he
definitely didn't look like one on
sunday all right next one for me and
there are plenty to choose from i guess
i gotta go with zeke i mean he would put
himself on the list
he's got the fumbling problem he's
trying to do too much he's let it get
into his head he's got a lot of work to
do to turn it around and try to to be
just don't try to do too much understand
you don't have an offensive line
understand you don't have dac don't try
to gain 25 yards on every play don't try
to win the game on every snap just do
what you can and just hold on to the
football and i know it's easier said
than done but that's where he needs to
get chris yeah i i uh it's unbelievable
i mean you just you never would have
expected that he would have had this
type of issue or done anything like that
uh i'm i'm shocked i really am and yeah
i get you picked it i wrote him down i
was going to be my next pick was going
to be zeke elliot i was hoping you were
going to forget it um
you know i'm gonna go with like
i'm gonna go with the baltimore ravens
defense
i am
because i expect more from them i hold
them to a high standard i mean that lead
against that team with no weapons to let
them come back and have a chance to tie
the football game i mean up 24-6 up 30
to 14.
i'm just shocked by that and it's not
just so just all the players too i'm
adding like wink martindale and some of
that too you know they they were over
aggressive down the stretch let carson
wentz just throw balls up one on one 50
50 balls all those type of things but
hey i you know me i like this ravens
team i like the ravens defense i'm a big
fan of wink martindale i i root for them
and to me yeah the way they kind of
managed the end of that football game
the other day and especially the way
they played on the defensive side i mean
they should have put that game away 10
minutes before that and it should have
been over with and done deal instead
they let philadelphia and once hang
around and make plays and almost tied
the damn football game
there's so much wrong with the new york
jets right now but i got to give the
goat horns to greg williams we pointed
this out yesterday he shouldn't have
been running his mouth last week about
how it's not the defense's fault they're
giving up all those points throwing
shade at the offense that's the last
thing this team needs especially on the
cusp of their last best chance to win a
game before the bye week and i don't
know at some level is he trying to
finagle the opportunity to be the
interim head coach i don't know but it
was a bad look for a bad team and it
yeah it does feel like he's going to be
the interim head coach and you know what
maybe that's the best punishment for him
you get to coach this thing all the way
to owen 16 after uh that there's a
change made
when the bye week comes following games
against the chiefs bills and patriots
over the next three weeks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports